hi this is wesley from google cloud and
welcome to serverless migration station
a serverless expedition mini-series
dedicated to helping developers
modernize their apps to using the latest
features available on one of our
serverless compute platforms
i'm joined by serverless expedition host
martin and our little friend porter the
train who will take us on our continuing
journey migrating from app engine blob
store to cloud storage
sounds great and glad to be here was
last time in module 15 we added app
engine blob store to our sample app what
are we doing today
now that we have blob store usage in our
app today's exercise is to migrate it to
cloud storage
check out the module 15 video and code
lab because we pick up from where it
leaves off in addition to cloud storage
we're doing three other migrations at
the same time
now wait wes did you really say we're
doing
one plus three that is four migrations
today why on earth would you do that
true it does sound like a lot the
primary focus is on app engine blobster
to cloud storage because we've already
covered the others for example moving
from the web app to framework to flask
is covered in module one and migrating
from app engine adb to cloud nab is
addressed by module two when moving to
the standalone cloud services we get the
bonus that they're available in python 3
meaning we can finally upgrade from
python 2. in fact the updated app will
run on both python 2 and 3 to help with
those migration efforts
okay that makes more sense we're trying
to help developers upgrade from app
engine's legacy bundle services to the
standalone cloud versions that's right
and this migration is no different
moving from bundled services like
blobstore and ndb for data store access
to standalone equivalents like cloud
storage or cloud ndb or cloud datastore
makes your apps much more portable in
case you ever need to upgrade to the
latest app engine runtimes or move your
code to our sister serverless platforms
like cloud functions or cloud run
sounds good i'm going to do this by hand
while you're explaining it to so point
me in the right direction for sure
martin links to everything are down
below earlier we recommended doing the
module 15 code lab so start with your
code from that exercise if you don't
have it clone the repo or download the
zip file and grab it from the module 15
folder follow the module 16 codelab as i
go through the migration and when
complete your code should basically
match what's in the module 16 folder
ready let's go to the computer and walk
through this migration
start by confirming you've got a working
module 15 app there are no third party
libraries we need to bundle so no pip
install nor loop folder here just run
gcloud app deploy to upload to the cloud
hit your app engine app see the form
upload a file or skip it and get to the
most recent visits page it works so now
we can update the app let's start with
the config files namely app.yaml in
module 15 we use the jinda2 built-in
library but because we're switching from
web app2 to flask and jinja comes with
flask delete this we're adding use of
cloud client libraries those require grp
cio and setup tools so add those cloud
storage in particular needs ssl so add
that too and select the latest versions
of all of these
if you're also porting to python 3
uncomment the line at the top and delete
all remaining lines in app.yaml because
there are no built-in libraries in the
second generation runtimes as they'll be
installed automatically one more time
for python 3. app.yaml should only have
the one line for the runtime and that's
it going back to python 2 we're now
using third-party libraries built-in and
non-built-in or those we need to vendor
bundle or copy with our app these
include flask and the cloud client
libraries put them in requirements.txt
the presence of both built-in and
vendored third-party libraries means we
need to add an app engine config.py file
with at least these lines in it this
file has been featured in many of the
other migrations covered in this series
if this is new to you see the installing
libraries for python 2 apps linked below
regardless create both files with the
contents you see here if reporting to
python 3 there's no rendering nor use of
app engine config.py and all third-party
libraries go into requirements.txt
that's it for config let's look at the
app itself at the top swap out all the
imports web app 2 is replaced by flask
instead of using gender 2 from web app
to extras it's built into flask app
engine blob store and andy b are
replaced by cloud adb and cloud storage
respectively the blobster handlers in
webup are replaced by a combo of the i o
standard lib module flask and worksug
utilities by default blobster writes to
a cloud storage bucket named after your
app's url you know project
id.appspot.com
because we're doing a direct port with
the cloud storage client library
google.auth is used to get the project
id to specify the exact same bucket name
as blobstore but realize you can change
it
the next block of code is to replace the
base handler specifying the use of jinja
2 as a template engine this is
unnecessary as jinja 2 is the default in
flask on the module 16 side we need to
instantiate the flask app as well as
create api clients for cloud ndb and
cloud storage finally we put together
the bucket name as described a moment
ago
creating a new visit and querying the
most recent visits doesn't really change
much
one difference is that data store calls
must be wrapped in a width block
affecting both store visit and fetch
visits
review the module 2 collab and video if
you need more info here
the other change is that because we're
no longer using blob store we can't use
a blob key property instead we'll just
exchange it for a file name string for
us here in module 16 things get really
interesting the rest of the way and
replacing use of the upload and download
handlers
the next step is to refactor the upload
handler instead of a class it's just a
function in flask the post method
becomes a decorator argument both check
if a file was uploaded or not if there
is a file upload it to cloud storage
then create a visit with all the
necessary info finally do a 307 redirect
to slash or home
for the view or download handler replace
the class with another flask function
both take the blob or file requested as
an argument the web app routes are at
the bottom while flask routes are all
decorators but you can see the calls to
slash view with the blob or file info as
part of the path it's then parsed by
each handler and requested from cloud
storage oh yeah and return a 404 if not
found
the lobster handlers do a bit more of
the dirty work hence why the
replacements have a little bit more code
the last thing to take care of is the
main handler both git and post methods
are merged into one function the get
provides an upload url while the post
fetches the most recent visits
regardless which are called the template
is rendered with the provided data since
both frameworks use jinja 2 no changes
are needed in the web template that
concludes the required updates to the
main application and the initial config
changes
since we're using third-party libraries
run the pip install command to copy the
third-party libraries into the lib
folder now upload to app engine with
gcloud app deploy and confirm the app
works identically to the module 15
version meaning an initial form with
optional file upload followed by the
most recent visits page
if it works you will have successfully
completed all four migrations by the way
the app is fully python 3 compatible now
make the earlier suggested change to
app.yaml to enable python3 delete both
app engine config.py and the lib folder
run gcloud app deploy and boom you've
got a live running python 3 version of
your app okay let's get back to the main
presentation no wait did you all notice
this other file main migrate dot py
what's that
yes it's an alternative version of
main.py it exists because updating the
data model from using blob key
properties to string properties made the
app backwards and compatible meaning it
won't be able to process older visits
with files created by blob store
this version of main.py bridges that gap
because it has both file properties and
has an etl function that normalizes blob
keys and cloud storage file names
meaning it can access files created by
blob store or cloud storage interesting
right martin
that's right wes in relapse you often
have to bridge between old and new data
you can tell users that their old data
is gone agreed and if you are starting
from scratch with no blob store files
use the normal main.py but if you're
transitioning and want to support files
created by blobstore and cloud storage
take a look at
main-migrate.py as an example of how to
cope with this scenario to help you deal
with issues like this in your apps
cool we want to make it easier for
developers to modernize their
applications
i'm ready to learn more about migrating
to cloud storage and i know you got some
reading for this
definitely down below are links to the
cloud stores migration docs as well as a
general documentation for both blobstore
and cloud storage
sounds good wes what are the next steps
for users to do after this migration
thanks for asking users can move off of
other bundled services like push tasks
and memcache those are covered by
modules 7 8 and 9 and 12 and 13
respectively
small app engine apps can consider
simplifying by moving to cloud functions
see module 11. and if containerization
is part of your new development workflow
consider moving your apps to cloud run
modules 4 and 5 cover how to do this
with and without docker respectively
and we hope to see you at one of those
migration stations or on another
serverless expedition soon in the
meantime this is wesley on behalf of
martin and porter wishing you safe
journeys